good morning this is an Barker I'm
actually in Tempe Arizona today so good
morning or good afternoon wherever you
are my my former roles actually were as
deputy director of the National Cancer
Institute and there I was able to do a
number of things that i'm going to be
reviewing today i am currently at
arizona state university where i am the
co-director of complex adaptive systems
here and i'm also directive director of
transformative healthcare networks and
i'm going to be talking to you today
about molecular based medicine what we
call personalized medicine or precision
medicine it's got a lot of names but
essentially its molecular based medicine
and I'm going to ask the question is is
this our best hope to finally defeat
cancer and i'll give you the take-home
message I'm pretty optimistic but there
are some issues and we're going to go
through those in some detail today I
encourage you to ask questions as we go
through the talk today and we'll try to
answer all of your questions and clarify
as we go through if that would be
helpful so so welcome everybody and
those folks that were just on with Chuck
Peru I hope you learned an enormous
amount about what the great things that
Chuck has done for the Cancer Genome
Atlas in terms of breast cancer so um
today we're going to we're going to walk
through several areas that I think are
going to be very important in
determining whether or not this is our
best hope for the finally defeating
cancer what is to talk about some of the
realities that we're facing in this
field and it's a very old field actually
goes back way beyond 1971 when we
actually when richard nixon nixon
actually approved the national cancer
institute the work started well before
then and continues obviously to this day
with a very very big enterprise behind
it including the National Cancer
Institute and certainly the private
sector and increasingly foundations and
others working in the research arena
the state of the science is is evolving
quite rapidly and driven in large
measure by advanced technologies most
especially whole genome sequencing and
next-gen sequencing which we'll talk a
bit more about and we want to talk about
sort of how do we how do we evolve this
strategy in molecular based medicine and
why do we think it's really important
and why we think that we should continue
down this road and if we continue down
this road where should we be looking and
what should we be looking for so and
then finally let's look at the near term
and the and a future in terms of things
that we have to do to really realize
this potential so so to get started
let's face some realities here cancer is
an extraordinarily daunting disease not
just the nature of this disease the
heterogeneity of the disease the
complexity etc but just the sheer
numbers if you look at cancer in the
United States we have about 1.6 million
new cases that we're going to diagnose
this year and I should tell you that's
substantially increasing men have about
a one in two lifetime chance of getting
cancer in women one and three five
hundred and eighty thousand plus people
will die this year from this disease
it's it's an enormous number and again
that's increasing about that's it's
going to be about twenty five percent of
our living population today and that's
that's an enormous number when you start
thinking at the size of our country an
interesting statistic that is a grim
reality for this country because of the
baby boomer generation is that
seventy-seven percent of cancer is
diagnosed in individuals over the age of
55 and if you think about the fact that
about 10,000 people are turning 65 each
day in the US you can start to imagine
that cancer is going to increase and its
projected increase somewhere in the
neighborhood of thirty percent in the
next 15 to 20 years and that's that's
all very bad news but the good news is
that they're about 13.7 million
survivors today
many more survivors and much of that is
due to some of the targeted treatment
them we'll be talking about the cost of
cancer is is well over 200 billion
dollars a year and that that's going to
increase enormously this is one of the
largest problems we have in healthcare
today and finally mortality rates
overall have not shifted all that much
starting to shift a little bit in the
last five or six years but not so much
since the 1950s due to the increased
numbers of people getting cancer and as
we'll talk about later that's an area
where we have to focus the reality is
just not a u.s. reality this is a world
problem and when I was at the NCI we
spent a lot of time talking to other
countries about their cancer problem and
as you can see in 2008 there were about
7.6 million cancer deaths projected by
2020 there will be about 10.3 million
and it's going up significantly from
there in if you look at 16 million new
cases in that same year that's going to
be an enormous burden for the world not
just for the US or for Europe or / China
but if you think about China China has
350 million smokers and as you know at
least in our country and around the
world about a third of cancer is caused
by smoking so this is a huge issue in
China and will be and become more of an
issue as time goes on so one of the
other realities we face is is metastatic
disease as you can see these numbers are
a little better than when I made the
slide about a little over a year ago but
if you have if you have metastatic
disease at the time of diagnosis your
chances of recovering and surviving your
disease might become much much less and
regional disease is still much more
curable than distant metastases and for
some of these tumors like pancreatic
cancer we really still don't do very
well in terms of really saving cancer
patients and these are areas that are
Armus focus for four Institute's like
the National Cancer Institute and for
many of the survivors groups so that's
all that's all about the daunting
statistics that we're going to consider
for the moment and that's heaven knows
that's enough but the reality of what
this is actually led to over the many
years that we've been trying to actually
cure this disease and treat this disease
more effectively is that we have a
pipeline or a drug development process
that hasn't done very well so if you
look at this slide you'll see that from
the time we start in the discovery say
of small molecules to improving
approving actually a drug FDA approving
a drug it costs us about a billion
dollars and it takes about 15 to 20
years now that is in large measure due
to the complexity of this disease and
the lack of effective biomarkers there
are other reasons but the heterogeneity
of the disease and complexity for cancer
is has been a daunting problem and
remains a daunting problem even as we
move toward molecular medicine if you if
you think if you think that it would be
appropriate and you have questions as we
go through this fog please ask them as
we go along so we don't have all of our
questions at the end so let's talk a
little bit now about the state of cancer
research and if you look at where we all
started down this road it started when
all the way back in nineteen ninety when
there was there was the national attempt
to sequence the human genome which
turned into a major major project a very
successful project one of the most
probably one of the most transformative
projects of our time if you look at what
that project actually really enabled it
was the ability for us to identify these
changes in jeans and changes in
chromosomes actually at every level of
the genome whether it was copy number
changes big changes on the genome
are in the chromosomes RNA expression
micro RNAs which are much more recent
but extraordinarily important point
mutations the proton and the epigenome
etc so if you go if you go to if you go
to literature today you will find all of
these areas being explored and if you
think about how far we've come in terms
of that knowing the numbers of genes
knowing the number of base pairs in DNA
and knowing that we are still pretty
dismal in terms of knowing function only
about fifty percent of what we know
about the genome in terms of mutations
or changes in the genome have actually
enabled us to understand function so
this is our challenge understanding
changes in the genome is step one
understanding of functional changes that
occur as a consequence is is step two
through whatever and we're we've got a
lot of work to do there and that in fact
is probably our biggest issue in terms
of realizing the promise of molecular
based medicine the other thing I want to
point out that at this stage and it is
an area of research for the cancer
community has been for many many years
and that is that cancer occurs in
context so the microenvironment the
architectural issues related to how DNA
gets expressed or how it gets
interpreted by a cell within a cell is
incredibly important the last thing I'll
point out is that you know this is a
this is a trip that we haven't been on
all that long the first oncogene was
actually discovered in in only in 1986
so this progress has been pretty rapid
and if you think about where we are now
versus where we can go I think we can
expect exponential progress of this
stage so I want I want to pause here for
a second and think about what it is that
really started us on this road and and
really catalyzed more thinking about
what how can we actually understand the
genome and is understanding the genome
our best ticket to really eliminating
suffering in depth due to cancer
hopefully curing a
more cancer so this is a drug that was
developed in and approved in 2002
gleevec imatinib for chronic myelogenous
leukemia and this is a very interesting
story and one that is worth knowing a
lot about because it has matured and
today we know a great deal more about
this drug and a great deal more about
this particular change in the genome
which has allowed us to understand a lot
more about other diseases so if you look
at this particular change in the genome
it's a fusion genome it's it's an
exchange actually between two
chromosomes chromosome 9 and chromosome
22 to create a new construct actually
and that new construct leads to a new
protein that new protein as brian druker
and his colleagues found out when they
started working on this particular
alteration the genome drives a great
deal of what happens in chronic mile on
this leukemia and so that drug was
approved in 2002 and lo and behold many
of those patients many of whom actually
were near death were virtually cured now
that was the good news the bad news is
cancer is extraordinarily intelligent I
put that in quotation marks disease so
there are all kinds of backup mechanisms
that cancers evolved and so we do have
resistance in a percentage of these
patients and we now have second and
third-generation drugs to treat these
patients but this was a really
instructive point and I think one that
influenced a lot of what came after in
terms of expecting that we would find a
lot more of these kinds of changes in
the genome that hasn't proven to be the
case but we have found one more recently
to be wrapped gene which actually is is
turning out to be a very important
change in the genome as well and we'll
come back to that one in a minute but
this has been it was instructive in for
a couple of other reasons this
particular drug was very effective in
CML but as it turns out it's
also effective against another change in
the genome called secant so this
particular drug this is an fdg-pet
response to just or gastrointestinal
tumors this drug actually is very
effective against these tumors and
actually a man is effective against
several kinds of tumors now and that's a
story that's going to be very
interesting if you start thinking about
this here's one change in the genome
that imatinib working against and
another one that it's also working
against it's it's it's a very
interesting sort of dynamic that's that
we're beginning to understand that these
genomes the changes some of these
changes are going to be common across
several cancers some of them to be very
unique so you've got to look at you got
to look at the drug very carefully and
and and tested in clinical trials
against several diseases so we in 2003
Francis Collins and I had a conversation
we had many conversations with our board
at the National Cancer Institute is it
time given given what had gone on in
discovering what we knew about the human
genome from the Human Genome Project is
it time to sit down and talk about doing
a big science project for the cancer
genome and the answer was yes we decided
to do that in 2003 so we set up the
Cancer Genome Atlas um some people like
it some people don't like it it's big
science I personally believe that we are
the stage in science where we need to
balance big science and our one or
individual investigator initiated
science the goal here was to identify
all the genomic changes in up to what
became 20 different cancers and I think
you heard from Chuck Peru on the last
talk about some of the things that TCG
items accomplished in breast cancer this
was a very big project everything in
this project was highly controlled from
the samples and the quality of the
samples to pretty much everything about
the data how the data was actually
deposited how the data elements were
selected how we manage that
in terms of the data repository and we
also had analytical teams to work on the
data and we had technology development
that both NHGRI and NCI funded during
that period so very big science very big
project and many publications now in
nature cataloging and various mutations
that we have found in TCGA some very
interesting some confirming what we
already knew which is an extremely
important step when you think about the
fact that thousands of people have
worked on these genomes and we need we
need confirmatory kinds of projects like
this to ensure ourselves that this is
that these data are real so we used
multiple technologies here we started
with with Sanger sequencing we worked
our way through and actually adopted
next-gen sequencing and we looked at
various states of the genome RNA
obviously changes in the DNA the
epigenome we did not consider we did not
work on the proteome in this project
specifically some of our colleagues did
in some of the center's and there were a
number of centers obviously working
together on this project and literally
hundreds of investigators so if you
think about the kinds of things that
come out of projects like this and there
are other projects like TCGA now out
there this was this was actually the
first two were we reported on which was
GBM or glioblastoma multiforme a it's an
extraordinarily lethal tumor as you know
at the time we started this
investigation with TCGA there wasn't
much in the literature that actually
would inform us about this tumor in
terms of how to treat it how to diagnose
it so what we were able to do is as we
as we worked as we worked our way
through this we were able to map these
map these changes in the genome pretty
systematically and this is expression
RNA expression and we were able to
actually sub classify these tumors and
this has been done
with ovarian cancer and other cancers
but essentially it also allowed us to
take the pathways and as you can see
here the rtk arrests pi3 kinase pathway
the p53 pathway the RV pathway these
were pathways that we knew a lot about
but we were able to map the genomes and
the changes in the genome cities
pathways which substantially improved
and increased our confidence that for
example the tyrosine kinases we know
they're important in cancer we know
they're important targets but this was a
great way to start to look at this and
there were new genes found here and this
is this is probably one of the best
databases out there or GBM many many
investigators now working on this tumor
and lots of new drugs coming along and
being tested for GBM unfortunately not
moving nearly as quickly as we would
like but I think in the next four to
five years you will see some significant
changes in the way GBM is diagnosed and
treated so if you look at what TCGA did
and several other of the large genome
projects including an international
project that actually used a lot of the
learning curves that we had developed in
TCGA the international cancer genome
project being run by tub by Tom Hudson
out of Canada but if you look at what
this has created we've kind of created a
sequencing tsunami now I mean we have we
have a lot of sequencing going on and
we're sequencing not just cancer but
certainly across many and almost all
diseases now but if you start to if you
start to look at if you start to look at
this it's really based not just on the
reduced reduced cost of sequencing
genomes but also on the amount of
information that's coming from the
genomes and nher is is recommending that
you know that we are to start to really
begin to systematically look at this
data and and and are creating new
approaches to that for analysis and and
other approaches but it's projected that
by the end of 2014 and there will be a
million genomes and
the total total global output is going
to be about 28 petabytes of data by 2014
that's an enormous amount of sequence an
enormous amount of information we don't
know how to manage that and it's a huge
challenge for us in cancer probably the
biggest challenge we have right now and
if you look at who's producing all this
data it's pretty much coming from
everywhere from the international
projects from TCGA from pretty much
everywhere and the nci-designated Cancer
Centers are engaged the pharma bio
companies certainly engaged and so we do
from the sequencing tsunami we now have
a big data tsunami and you hear a lot
about Big Data these days very important
and particularly important in terms of
cancer so increasingly it is about Big
Data increasingly many of you out there
that are working in the genomespace know
how challenging this is in terms of
analysis it's it's a it's a huge problem
and one that as I say NCI is working on
NIH is working on starting lots of
private initiatives in this area
especially also in Europe and there
there's a book out that you haven't
picked it up yet you might want to look
at it this is now becoming known as sort
of the fourth paradigm science but
essentially this is what biomedicine is
going to become or is quickly becoming
information and big data is in fact
going to be the future biomedicine so
those of you out there that trained in
differential equations and having
forgotten your ear computational skills
you're going to be well served in the
future because this is it's going to
become increasingly important we don't
have enough people trained in this space
I wish we had a great deal more I know
many of our colleges and universities
are trying to catch up in this area now
so if you look at the data explosion in
cancer and in biomedicine overall it
takes three different forms in terms of
variety there's just different forms of
the things that we're sequencing and
fine
out about the genome the shear rate or
the velocity is almost exponential now
and the amount of volume as i said is is
absolutely unprecedented so if you look
at all the data types and you put all of
this together in terms of the multi
multi dimensionality of this data 28
petabytes that we were talking about
before starts to look realistic and
pretty daunting in terms of the amount
of analysis we have to do and as I said
we now only know about fifty percent of
the functional changes that are involved
with the data that we know something
about so very very big problem so the
beauty of this era that we're living in
right now and I think we'll all look
back on this era as one where we're
beginning to open a new window into
understanding the complexity of this
disease this big data really if we
manage it correctly and we put the right
teams together I think we can start to
decon dilute the complexity of this
disease in ways that we wouldn't have
guessed even five years ago and I'm
going to spend a minute on that at the
end of the talk so the way we're
starting to think about cancer and the
way I like to think about cancer under
way I'd like you to start thinking about
cancer is as follows this is a complex
information driven system under the
influence of evolution and it evolves in
space over time now that's a lot to
think about but I would challenge you to
start thinking about the
four-dimensional genome not just the two
dimension genome because whatever the
cause on the side of your screen it's my
left I don't know if it's your left it
can be inherited which is not not a
large percentage of cancer but it can be
caused by so many different things
including smoking as we mentioned before
and certainly diet but wherever you
start in terms of the changes in the
genome everything after that is actually
under the influence of evolution
all the way up to the malignant state
but this is a system composed of many
subsystems so we need to start thinking
about this to understand function we're
going to have to understand a lot more
about the four-dimensional genome so if
you look at the way we see out saw
patients and you see patients as you
sequence them even though if you look at
this going back to the sub B subtyping
of GBM every every line on there
actually is an individual patient no two
patients are going to be exactly the
same but there are common features in
these pathways that unites them almost
like snowflakes I put snowflakes on one
side of the screen here because as you
know in physics there are there are some
really interesting structural features
and physics of snowflakes that make them
look very much the same on a gross basis
but very very different when you get
down to them to the Nano space and so
the same thing may very well we may need
to start to thinking of patients and of
the science of when we're dealing with
in this same way so the the pathways
that we're talking about are quite
common the extent to which patients
changes occurs in those pathways is
quite different so finally I want it I
want to turn to the question that we
asked when we started this conversation
and that is is molecular base notice
that our best chance to defeat cancer
and I am going to give you a lady right
now because I want to I want to bring up
a few issues and their issues that we
all have to deal with to realize the
potential of whatever we have here and I
think we do have an extraordinarily good
opportunity to do a lot more about this
disease so there are several barriers
I'm going to just I'm going to talk
about two of those barriers this morning
but one that's close to my heart is this
issue of high-quality data best
practices and standards for the areas
that are driving biomarker development
and and biomarkers are actually signals
of either normal seeing in a cellular or
a process that actually signals that
something is okay or something is not
okay in the case of disease the end but
there are other their other barriers
here like as i said before translating
data and the knowledge is probably one
of our biggest barriers clinical trials
and realigning and redesigning clinical
trials to accommodate a personalized
medicine approach economic realities of
this who's going to pay for it engaging
patients this has to be patient centric
and then some of the ethical issues that
surround us a whole issue of molecular
medicine all things that have to be
dealt with but i want to talk a little
bit about this issue of standards and
quality in this space and then also how
do we talk and think about this
four-dimensional genome so we can do a
lot more than we're currently doing so
if i if i take you back to the Cancer
Genome Atlas for a second we learned a
lot in that particular project about the
value of standards and the value of
actually having high-quality tissues of
actually sourcing those tissues in ways
that we're there they're collected under
standard operating procedures it turns
out to be pretty important and even
though technology is moving very quickly
now the significance of reproducibility
of data and reproducibility of findings
is incredibly important especially again
around biochemical biomarkers and I
would argue that quality tissues and
quite an access to quality tissues is
going to be critical and is going to be
more and more difficult in the future
because we're getting better and better
actually at preserving preserving
tissues and also in preserving life so
we're we're by the time we get around to
taking out many of these tumors we've
actually shrunk them and so we're we're
actually preserving life but we're also
we're also decreasing the amount of
tissue that were running up available so
but one thing we learned here and it was
a learning curve that cost us time and
it also cost us resources was that at
that time and I'm not sure how much has
changed only about a third of our
tissues in the country were good enough
to use in the early going of the Cancer
Genome Atlas
and so quality is important and I think
it's now become very important to most
of you out there and the second area
that is I think reflects some of these
problems and not just in tissues but
also lack of standards and in the
technology space is that we are not very
good at developing biomarkers and well
we're not very good at all in developing
biomarkers we've discovered about
150,000 in the literature about a
thousand of those have actually made it
through the FDA only about 1.3 per year
since the early 90s and the reasons are
complex but a lot of them have to do
with reproducibility of data and the
quality of the analytes that we're
working on so this has to be fixed
otherwise we can like all the
discoveries we want but we have to have
decent biomarkers to to pair up with the
kind of drugs that we want to get
approved so if you look at what we're
going to do about the biomarker problem
in the standards problem overall for
biomarkers we don't currently have a
prospective way to think are throughout
the think our way through a pipeline to
actually develop an end-to-end approach
to biological development it just
doesn't exist it's been done piecemeal
over many years and Janet Woodcock who's
the director of the Center for drugs at
the FDA has said it's an on FDA's job to
develop the standards for biomarkers
it's the job of the affected communities
so I'll just mention one of the things
that we have done here at Arizona State
University in actually in collaboration
with many partners the critical path
Institute the International Genome
consortium Mayo Clinic t Jen and many
national groups as well now is to take
this problem on so we've developed
something called the National biomarker
development lines will be launching that
in January of 2014 and our mission
actually as this pipeline indicates is
to create a standard set of standards
and best practices so that we can
actually come up with a prospective
predict
well in the end pipeline for the express
purpose of bringing rigor and
predictability to biomarker development
we think that will really really help
our communities to get their drugs
approved to get their biomarkers
approved and accelerate the pace by
which we can get these targeted drugs
into patients so it's a big tent if any
of you interested in joining me in this
and joining our colleagues in this just
email me and we love to have you join us
so coming back to this issue of
complexity I want to spend my final few
minutes here on talking about how this
cancer community can embrace complexity
and think about think more deeply about
the four-dimensional genome this is
where progress will be made in my
opinion so coming back to cancer as a
complex system and all the excuse me all
the all the discussion that we've had
about this sorry it's so many you can
still get you can still make mistakes
when you have everything under your
control there but coming back to this
idea that cancer is a complex system
it's not just a complex system in the
sense that you're looking at it in a
linear fashion you have to look at it in
terms of the subsystems and the
interaction that goes on in in
three-dimensional space and over time
and and time has a big component in
cancer when you think about it because
it takes and with many of these cancers
it takes decades to develop these
diseases so we need to understand a lot
more about how these changes in the
genome get expressed in terms of this
four-dimensional idea and if we can do
that then we'll start to take what we
now look at is pathways and this is a
hand and Weinberg slide that lots of
people show but essentially cancer is it
is an emergent system it's it's actually
the consequence of the interaction of so
many of these pathways over time and in
space so just looking at these pathways
as we diagram them today it's convenient
but it's not that simple and so we have
to start thinking about these pathways
as they interact and how this disease
emergence and so very very
important for all of us to start
changing our mindset about the linearity
of pathways that's not the way it works
in nature and it's not the way it
certainly it works in in the human body
so if you start to think about this and
let me just click quickly through this
and click back sorry this is the problem
with animation so if you start to think
about how information drive systems
within systems then if you look at
cancer as a system they're all kinds of
length scales starting with cancer it
starts down at their genome or even
below the genome actually at the at the
molecular level or even at the atomic
level we don't do much in cancer at that
level yet but I predict someday we will
but essentially you've got to start
thinking across scales all the way from
DNA up to the organism and if you look
at the variables then you you you're
going to move from the changes in DNA
all the way up to the organism and these
systems the bay the laws of physics it
doesn't necessarily explain their
behavior because it's an emergent system
so the subsystems can can actually
behave in some way but the emergent
system may behave differently and we see
that in cancer and heterogeneity
actually produces a lot of things that
we can't control so these behaviors that
we see in cancer whether it's the
immersion of Miss merchants and
metastasis world resistance are the
ability to actually physically they sell
some route from one place to the other
you can't you can't really explain that
by understanding the components so each
of these components is part of a complex
system and I would argue that's the
future how do we understand complex
systems cancer is information it's
decoded in context and so shape matters
context matters infrastructure matters
this is all information and the
information is being translated between
the context of architecture and DNA and
people who worry about the
microenvironment are starting to really
make contributions I think in this field
so I think the future belongs two teams
of people who are going to work together
from theorists in terms of evolutionary
theory information theory IT and
computational and bioinformaticians and
physics and engineering helping us to
understand some of the physics of these
systems and then biologists who actually
are developmental biologist cancer
biologists etc and I think this
increasing complexity across all of the
areas that we think about from the DNA
up to the organism is going to be the
future of the way we think and work with
this disease and other complex chronic
diseases but cancer is especially going
to be relevant to this kind of approach
so I have guarded optimism that
molecular based medicine is our best
hope to finally defeat cancer I think
we're starting to show some real hope in
that regard and here's the best hope of
all if this is just a list of some drugs
that have been approved for cancer
starting with herceptin which was
actually at first to the targeted drugs
approved all the way back I think in two
thousand if I remember correctly this is
this is actually her to which is an
amplified gene in breast cancer and it
was actually worked on and pushed
forward by Denny Simon at UCLA and is
used very almost universally in breast
cancer today and I'm just going to
highlight a couple of others here
obviously egfr expression in terms of
Erbitux is now is that we have several
approved drugs beyond the list it's on
here k RS is a very interesting example
of understanding the genome in more
detail then we would have thought even
important a few years ago the wild type
of this particular gene these cancers
respond if in fact they are mutated k
rush genes they generally do not respond
it's not it's not an absolute guarantee
that if you're wild type that you'll
respond but very major percentage of
those patients do but what's really
important is knowing who's not going to
respond so this is a another example of
unapproved drugs that series of drugs
now to treat this disease for
patience especially with wild-type ke RS
were recently the brf gene discovered
many years ago now has been shown to be
very important in melanoma and we have
we have several drugs now approved from
metastatic melanoma just in the last
five years along with and i should say
all of these drugs have approved
biomarker tests now there are issues
with the tests and one of the things
that are going back to the plans of the
National biomarker development alliance
we hope to work out these issues in
terms on building better biomarker test
even her too to this day starts
continues to be an issue so we'll come
back to we'll come back to that at the
end potentially with questions so I'm
getting the end of my time and I want to
make sure that I have some time to
discuss with you some of these issues so
in the near future here's what I think
some things here are some things that I
think will need to happen to realize
this whole future of personalized
molecular based medicine number one we
have to engage patients in all aspects
of this process this is about
personalized patient-focused medicine
and so we need to do clinical trials and
inform clinical trials of patients and
so engaging patients is going to be
critical and I think more and more
scientists understand that and are
beginning to work with survivors groups
in ways that we haven't done before and
that's going to be very productive we
have to know that our molecular
signatures or our biomarkers are
extremely robust and reproducible now as
you know the literature there's been
some literature recently showing that we
have some issues in that regard some
actually a fair percentage of some of
the work done in biomarker science
especially it's not been reproducible
and we need to know that there's no bias
in that work at the nadir of high
quality etc because that's the work
that's going to get translated by the
pharmaceutical companies large amount of
dollars are going to be invested and we
need to be very careful that we are in
the discovery community producing robust
data that's translatable and
suddenly producible we need we really
need to start engaging more with
computational experts and mom orders and
we have this is occurring now it's I
think it's still pretty modest and you
know my my advice is to take a
mathematician to launch and interest
them in your science and interest them
in your data because if we're going to
functionalize this data we have to
engage people who really understand how
to look at data and there are people
that outside our field to know a lot
more about this than we do for example
people who poor cast the weather they
have great models to look at huge big
data sets earthquake monomers I mean so
it may sound a little strangely DD The
Economist's there are other people who
know how to look at big data sets we
need to learn from them we need to
engage with them very difficult but
doable and a lot of people would love to
work with us especially the googles and
and Microsoft folks of the world those
are people who we need to engage with we
knew we need new and much better
clinical trial models than we currently
have especially for our biomarker driven
clinical trials and we need we need
trials like the I spy to trial one that
I was able to work on and help to enable
it when I was the National Cancer
Institute still involved with that trial
led by mrs erman and dawn Barry now
moving to ice 53 but this is an adaptive
trial that allows us to look at lots of
biomarkers and lots of drugs if you
don't know about ice by two you can go
to the literature there are several
several publications out there now on
ice by one and I spy two and also the
battle trial elegant md anderson and
other trials there's a new lung cancer
trial coming along as well so another
thing we need is these best practices
standards guidelines for biomarkers
which don't exist again that's something
that I'm taking on and I'm hoping that
some of you will want to join me in that
we need the evolutionary biologist in
volunteer we don't we don't have great
strengths in terms of evolution in
cancer we know that it's very important
but we we haven't thought about how you
actually model to prospectively
understand for example resistance and I
think evolutions incredibly in
born in terms of understanding
resistance to the kittatinny drugs that
we're men stirring and then last but not
least for this field to be important
enough for payers to actually pay for it
which is going to be critical whether
you know whether you're in that whether
you're in the payer community or in the
development community or in the
discovery community there has to be a
value proposition here so we we the
scientific community is going to have to
demonstrate the value of likely based
medicine so that we can we can actually
entice the payers and encourage the
payers to pay for this and that's not a
small issue because the value
proposition me needs to be demonstrated
in very sound ways and in clinical
trials finally in the more distant
future I think a lot of things are going
to change they're going to really
accelerate progress in this space of
molecular based medicine first of all we
need to understand more about the
information that's driving complexity
whether its use of models or actually
sort of the definition of state space as
physicist see it or mathematically
modeling the information that we need
but we need to understand what it is
that is most important in terms of D
convoluting the complexity of this
disease especially the pathways in the
interacting pathways so we can identify
these sensitive nodes which are going to
be our bio signatures in the future I
think so coming back to this idea of
evolution in context we need we need to
actually engage with scientists who
understand and measure bits of
information flow in systems and how
cells make decisions and cells do make
decisions they actually decide to go
down one path or another based on
information and we're getting to a stage
now where we can start to ask those
kinds of very difficult questions so
again I think the engagement of some of
the physicists mathematicians are going
to be very important and I know I sound
like a broken record on this but very
important that we take biology to this
convergent step so we can engage
these broader teams finally I think that
you know the dynamics and information
content that we need to figure out in
terms of cellular communication it were
just on the just on the edge of that and
so things like chemical gradients what
are what are signals in cancer and
chemical gradients is only one way to
sell signal but there are lots and lots
of other ways and those signaling nodes
are really what we need to go after in
terms of understanding how information
is transferred finally these pathways
for cancer are extremely robust
evolution has actually selected for them
so we need to describe that robustus so
we can understand how we can overcome it
and their this these robust pathways are
selected for and selected for and
selected for every time we give a drug
you need to also begin to define the
information that defines metastatic
disease so we won't we won't care about
a study disease until we understand
where does the information reside how is
the information transferred and how can
we stop it and I think that's going to
be key in also you know what is the
physics of these processes around
information finally cancerous tissue to
an organ-specific and we need really to
put more of our effort on understanding
the structural information in the
infrastructure that is that is the
tissues and the cells that actually
translate what comes from the genome
very very important big community in our
cancer world and I think they're going
to make an enormous amount of progress
in the next few years maybe we need a
Cancer Genome Project for the
microenvironment it wouldn't be
surprised so I'm going to stop there we
have about 15 minutes left for questions
you can send your questions in and we'll
try to answer them and I'm going to go
some of you have already put some
questions up and I want to I want to
take some of those on now
and then we'll we'll come back and close
so here's a comment that is long but let
me see if I can get it so it's a
question about secondhand smoke it says
is the number of cancers tributed to
smoking taking into account secondhand
smoke and the fact that a third world
smoker sorry it's a very long question
are smoking poor cigarettes lower grade
of cigarettes that's a very interesting
question I don't know the answer to the
quality of the cigarette issue but I do
know that the number i gave you does not
include the issue of secondhand smoke
I'm only talking about primary smokers
so that's uh that's another problem and
a very big problem obviously for the
families of these folks so so Titans is
a second question on biomarkers here
talking about by Omar slit and Lawton
biomarkers except protein biomarkers for
complicated pathways how reasonable is
it to study pathway gene expression
biomarkers will n be da except these
kinds of research efforts the answer is
yes because i think i think expression
biomarkers are going to be very
important in terms of pathway biology
very difficult to actually interpret
very difficult to really understand and
correlate with changes in disease but I
think there is I think we're entering an
era where we can with our computational
friends begin to develop algorithms to
capture the amount of information that
would be an expression profile and there
are people working on that so I think
this is a great area I think it's one
that we should not underestimate but we
do need to think about some of the
practical considerations of
standardizing the approaches and the
best practices the guidelines which many
of you have worked on over the years we
don't need to reinvent a lot of wheels
here so so the answer is yes very
important as a matter of fact I think
may
morley important most important may be
of some of the bio signature issues so
are we collecting data from thyroid
cancer patients as well I haven't
mentioned it I haven't mentioned a lot
of cancers but thyroid cancer actually
is you know very serious problem and yes
there are several groups collecting a
lot of information on thyroid cancers I
don't believe I don't have the data in
front of me I don't believe that I think
we have tissues for the Cancer Genome
Atlas for the thyroid cancer I don't
think that cancer has been has been run
by the group's yet it was not in the top
20 but there are several groups that
have that are sequencing thyroid tissues
and I think we will have good I think we
will have good data on thyroid cancer
it's a really interesting one and and
essentially one that we should be
looking at more carefully it is it is a
big problem in certain countries more so
than in the u.s. so my favorite question
what is the four-dimensional gene well
it's my term for what we need to do and
it's a bit of a play on words granted
but if you think about the way we're
thinking about the genome today
essentially if you lay out a sequence
and I don't know how many of you have
looked at a genome sequence but probably
a lot of you have by now you know we're
laying out a lot of zeros and ones
essentially is what we're reading from
the genome visual information in two
dimension two dimensional space so what
I'm asking us to do is to think about
moving up in terms of thinking about
four dimensional genomes in the sense
that let's think about let's think about
that genome in space three dimensional
space and over time which would be the
fourth aspect so essentially it's a way
to to bring together the
functionalization of the genome so I
think I there i'm quoting this phrase i
don't know if i coined it to someone or
somebody else coined it but i like it
and hopefully we could pick up on it and
start thinking about how to really delve
into the four-dimensional genome not
just the two-dimensional gel we're right
now into the four-dimensional genome
producing
it's a big data but I would predict
there's going to be a lot of progress
and that especially in understanding
that that configuration between sort of
spatial issues and how how information
is transferred between the architecture
of the cell and and the digital changes
that occur in the genome and it's a
little bit I think it's hard for us to
wrap our mind around the fact that the
genome is digital information it is
zeros and ones it's it's it's very much
like a computer program and it's an
extraordinarily complex computer program
we know something about it but we need
to know a lot more and there's a lot and
when a genome Marshall actually that we
don't know probably than we do know so
how can if this is how can you get
involved and help to achieve your vision
of how cancer is defeated well there are
so many ways they would take me a lot
more than the 89 minutes I have left
here to tell you but if you're if you're
a scientist then I hope that you're
working in this space of accelerating
progress against cancer whether it's in
the basic science space which i believe
is incredibly important I think a lot of
our advances are going to come from
fundamental science in the future
whether it's in a translational space
and you think about how do you actually
develop very very high quality
biomarkers or how you develop very very
excellent drugs if you're in that if
you're in the farm industry or if you're
in a clinical trial space how do you do
better clinical trials if you're a
patient there are over 800 survivors
groups out there that you can get
engaged with if you're a professional
society then we're you know we're
focusing on everything for example in
the american association for cancer
research work put more focus on policy
we're focused on basic science
translational science clinical science
so there are so many ways and and
finally make sure that you're talking to
Congress about supporting cancer
research because right now NIH and NCI
overall are taking a big hit and we need
our we need our
fundamental science to be supported we
need our clinical investigators to be
supported so one of the things that
everybody can do is write a letter and
say we want to support research so
there's a question here that is one that
is is a very big deal and want to really
worries me a lot and that is this issue
of most cancers are diagnosed in late
stages specifically stomach cancer when
possible stomach cancer is in fact
treatable now but not as treatable as we
would like is in an advanced stage so
this question that's that's brought up
here is a really critical one is how do
we actually find this tumor earlier it's
a it's a similar problem that we have
with pancreatic cancer or GBM and others
and I think now with with with gastric
cancer especially and it's an accessible
cancer certainly you can you can you can
take biopsies you can do work with some
in cancer that you can't do with so many
other cancers and so I am hopeful for
stomach cancer and it's by the way its
emerging again in this country I mean
you should know it's caused by h pylori
its emerging again as a problem in this
country and in younger people we don't
know why particularly but it is and I am
hopeful that we'll use this very
powerful genomics tool we have to begin
to find those very key genomic changes
and we can start looking for this tool
or much earlier and I think it is one
that we can start to look at in much
much earlier than we are now and I'm
hopeful on that cancer as I'm hopeful on
everything but I think Esther cancer is
one of those where we can do a great
deal more the next question is do I see
a link between cancer and autoimmune
disease well I trained as an
immunologist so I tend to see a link
between immunity and almost everything
autoimmune disease as you know is
extraordinary problem producing a whole
range of diseases I don't know the
answer to your question in terms of is
there
direct link but there are certainly
diseases where we have a proliferation
of cells and and some of these pathways
I think maybe overlapping and the whole
issue of the immune system in cancer
overall is coming together and this last
year has kind of been a year for any no
therapies I didn't mention as I was
going through that last couple of slides
but FDA actually approved since july of
2013 and are 12 and up to today has
approved 11 new cancer drugs that's
amazing two and two immunotherapies so
immunotherapy and this whole issue of
using the immune system is becoming very
mainstream and very effective and the
understanding of the intersection of
autoimmunity in cancer i think is going
to be very important maybe not for all
cancers but potentially for some cancers
but at the moment we don't have that
many people working in the space so if
you are working in that space I wish you
luck I think it's very hard it's a very
hard area they're hard problem the one
that has a long promise so another
question is a public linkedin community
project a good idea is we have already
started one would you help us I'll help
anybody is you know me I'm very much the
constantly volunteer I have a day job
but I'll help anybody I love the only
ten idea I think it's very important and
I would be a way to get you know get
credentials out there and we know people
we could turn to for help so the next
question is long our continuum models
that consider unsteady state diffusion
and chemical reaction useful to analyze
and our continuum models that consider
unsteady state diffusion and chemical
reaction useful to analyze and interpret
some of the large databases that you
mentioned and have there been
significant advances in quantifying the
kinetics of tumor growth let me answer
the first questions first the answer is
yes this whole issue of the continuum
that you're talking about in terms of
cancer isn't it is not at equilibrium
this is an unsteady state and its
one that lends itself to the model what
you're talking about so I would say yes
the Mongoose you're talking about would
be a very high value in the cancer space
especially in terms of some of the big
data you're talking about for some of
the cancers that have that have great
promise to be analyzed in this way and
then have there been significant
advances in quantifying the kinetics of
tumor growth I think kinetics in the way
that you're talking about it not as much
as we would like we do understand some
better I think some tumors better than
others but in terms of having a real
handle and predictability on tumors in
terms of kinetics not yet but I think as
we involve more physicist I think we
will get there when I'm charming a lot
of questions which do you think will
play a greater part in demonstrating the
value proposition of personalized
medicine I think it will be diagnostics
and I'll stop there and I'll say that's
the biggest stuff it's the biggest
barrier we have but I think it could be
also be the most productive because it
has the biggest payoff assuming we
identify the right patients for the
right drugs any comments on the unusable
models to study the evolution of the
genome very powerful very useful and I'm
hoping we see more of it in the space
and it's a repetitive question can i
comment on the role of computational
experts with protein biomarker discovery
very very important some of the major
advances in this space will be made by
computational experts working in the
proteomics space it is as close as we're
going to get to the state space and
understanding the state space state
space of cancer so drug treatment pushes
cancer the progression and your own
resistance which is a major change
mutations what do we need to obtain
approval of the diagnostics and run
together you need reproducibility and
you need predictability and obviously
you need efficacy and
I I think that that will become more
predictive as we get better in the
diagnostic space so before I run out of
time I want to just look at the last
list of questions and see here's an
interesting one how do i see emotional
factors in terms of cancers can plug
cancers complexity I wish we knew the
answer that we know that stress and
other issues are important but we don't
know why I wish more of our scientific
community wouldn't look at that it's
very difficult to study for
predisposition to cancer is
prophylactics it's prophylaxis promising
promising extraordinarily difficult so
I'm going to stop there i didn't get to
every question i'm sorry about that but
you ask a lot of great questions i am
optimistic that that molecular vice
therapy is is going to take us much
further than we are in terms of
defeating cancer is it the ultimate
answer I think it could be if in fact we
engage the communities that I spoke
about to bring everyone to the
conversation and understand this
four-dimensional genome how the genomics
is actually interpreted in people so
thank you very much for joining me today
and have a great day